Samsung is officially discontinuing
their Galaxy Note 7 smartphone because
they've been randomly bursting into
flames like Grandma falling asleep with
a cigarette in her mouth
let it go she's gone combine her Samsung
combined Samsung with a hoverboard and
discount vape pen and you've got a great
ensemble for that hip tech-savvy
millennial who loves being on fire all
the bad but there's some brilliant grand
theft auto modders who have added the
galaxy to the game's weapons store take
a look
I mean sure you know it looks dangerous
but at least it has a headphone jack no
I have not been mad about this for too
long you have been mad about it long
enough I mean yeah I have the iPhone 7
plus and the pictures are amazing
particularly in low light but I just
want headphones which is why God put two
holes in a phone its headphone jack not
headphone and Steve comedians this what
just happened comedians this looks
really bad for Samsung but they are the
world's biggest smartphone maker so can
they come back from this scandal Ron
Funches oh yeah they'll be just fine I
don't know if you noticed but this
entire year has been a dumpster fire
yeah that's true that's true yeah points
al Jackson
they gotta spin it man Samsung's got to
be like look this only happens to our
phone if you like your own statuses on
social media yeah of course they're
gonna survive they're Korean like I am
and we create a Gangnam style